so what do we do to change this so you
for example you're on or a TV now which
is an online news network we here at the
Young Turks were an online news network
I firmly believe that this is the future
of new so as you can we reach three
million people and footboard you do they
go it'll grow yeah in another grotto
it'll all balance yeah but I predicting
the future in this business is even
possible yeah there is that when I
started in radio in miami in 1957 the
university of miami owned an FM station
and FM was considered background music i
listen to FM right they gave that
station to the University of Miami the
University of Miami later sold that
station which became the number one
powerhouse station in Miami if you'da
said in 1957 hey FM is going to really
take off frequency much come on right
you're kidding so I i I've learned not
to predict right and it did okay for
about the last 50 years or so they've
they've been ok wrong so if we can't
predict it what what do you make of the
general partisan nature of news cuz to
me that's been the thing in the last 10
years that really use it that's one
thing about CNN that has CNN has stayed
in the middle which is a tough place to
be yeah do you thought that's hurt them
in a way because everyone is so partisan
and is selecting on CNN's credit I'm
happy that they have stayed not they've
strayed a little sometimes you'll see
opinions mm-hmm I don't see how would I
growing base um I always thought that my
opinion as an interviewer didn't count
but I was there to learn from what the
guests thought I left my ego at the door
the name my show was in the name of the
show was Larry King Live so I'll be back
say to you i know i saw was who what
where when why and the guest counted on
a lot of me shows the guest is a prop
for the host the host use the word i'll
I is irrelevant I don't care what the
host things I killed the if I never if I
got a lawyer I don't know more lower
than a lawyer I never voted
the Senate I never carried a gun as
weapon in war I never performed an
operation how could I know more about
medicine than a doctor yeah okay you
know so i might have my personal
opinions on things but i certainly value
the guests and what that guest has to
say I may not agree with it so let it
come through me as a conduit yeah I
think that's lost so when you had
moments that you really disagreed with
someone on air g spot was then in moral
issues yeah to me that the hardest part
was in the races racial issue when I had
to interview George Wallace the Governor
of Alabama nearly he changed
significantly that was tough and
sometimes I did get into arguments but I
found that in those moral areas when I
got into an argument what happen was it
may have seemed exciting you didn't
learn anything it was just two people
yelling at each other yeah and that's
effective but you know ratings ara
Jackie Gleason was a mentor of mine and
a great man and Jackie told me something
you know pal he goes you say pal I could
put intercourse on television on CBS
Tuesday night for three hours I'm gonna
wipe you up you might as well not even
go anywhere else I own America right
that's not talent right and that was
before Lucy could even put the beds
together so right yeah 13 of course yeah
if you could titillate this the mind of
people in appeal to their parade
interest I'm going to own the night yeah
takes no talent